hello everybody my name is the benefit
inspector and I'm a machine learning
scientist and Phillips and I'm also the
organizer of machine learning Meetup
- if you are not familiar with it and
it's an exception in recent years became
a healthcare company and it invests a
lot in healthcare in general and of
course medical imaging and by the way we
are currently looking for a machine
learning scientist so if you're
interested but we're in - okay so those
of you from the north
it can be great okay and so let's start
deep learning and medical imaging so
what we are going to talk about
so first we'll try to understand what is
medical imaging and of course the deep
learning trend for medical imaging then
we will deep dive into the challenges in
medical imaging in detail and we will
take a look on segmentation methods just
to try to understand you know why this
trend happens and what happening exactly
and at the end we'll take a look on the
recent trend and potential future
directions of where this field is going
okay so what is my guruji you have
different modalities you have a city
beta a mandate ultrasound x-ray but also
things like digital pathology this also
can be medical imaging some really very
high variability of what it can be and
what is more interesting is you know
what they're looking on in medical
imaging
what are the research areas there so
first there is this image acquisition
step right so now you're taking with say
a CT scan you have to
how translate the physics right to to
the images and what we get from a CT
scan our images like that so yeah you
can see them here so those are slices
kind of cutting the body those are
called axial slices and and then of
course there is a lot of algorithmic
efforts to produce those images alright
so this is one part another part is
image manipulation okay so now it
produces images we want to make them
better
maybe we want to produce in super
resolution we're going to do noise
reduction things like that to make them
in the best possible resolution right so
those are kind of big research areas and
we have you know another type of
research areas which is more like a post
processing so now when we have those
images those are 2d images maybe we can
do something more with them maybe we can
operate in 3d and you know give some
added value to the physician so here we
have things like registration so now we
said we have patient which was carried
on several times and we want to compare
the different scans so we need to do an
administration are between these scans
then we have detection and the
segmentation so anything bit of anything
right there it can be I would say
detection of lesions and segmentation of
organs and lesions and you know vessels
you know many many things and the reason
that we want this segmentation is that
we want to perform to qualify right and
quantitatively what is going on so let's
say if you know for the first Pacific we
don't want to know how much it brought
so
really wanted segmentation to be precise
and we want it in 3d right and of course
there are additional problems like
retrieval and at the end of the day we
are also getting more and more into a
computer and the diagnosis really
crucification from things like
prediction of cancer let's say within a
year and from the current skin okay
things like that so those are also in
the space and and to make things more
complicated we don't have money images
we have also metadata in even with the
scan itself we have text and also we
have a radiology reports we have
potentially medical records so we can
you know enhance those algorithms not
only within imaging data but with
additional data and just to mention
another kind of research space is you
know our kind of workflow improvement so
you know just to improve the workflow
for radiologists have also not been but
anyway today we'll focus on the
segmentation and segmentation is really
a simulation and detection are really
the bread and butter of this field and
kind of the basic stuff that we're doing
ok so not be planning ok I guess most of
you are familiar with deep learning and
they are familiar with the fact that you
know the neural networks have been here
and since the 90s and then at some point
they became much less popular and in
2012 and there was kind of new revival
of those networks with the new brains
name be planning a
with the network called Alex net that
actually won the large-scale natural
images of a competition and not only it
won this competition the error reduction
at the time was more than ten percent
which is was really mind-blowing for
this kind of competition and it really
sends them you can see it's trending
it's really rising this nicely and you
know declining was applied to a lot of
stuff okay now let's look on the
planning in marriage so here you can see
somewhat different picture this is 2012
but still we don't have you know this
price but a little bit more in 2014 and
2015 and suddenly started something
happened in 2016 right and 2017 and and
here did this we just don't know yet
right there then then this year still
don't know okay so something happened
here in 2016 or maybe even in 2015 but
really started this revolution also in
the medical imaging domain sorry why do
the numbers like women okay oh the
numbers this this was actually the
numbers are from the number of papers
that were found in PubMed search PubMed
is you know if you're looking for
articles in the medical domain and this
is the place for you
okay so there I just typed a bit
planning and medical imaging and this is
protocol and you can't get the graph
from that so yeah it's not a Google
Trends but it's kind of maybe even more
reliable than them this is a little 258
their permutations so many obviously
those are publications for medical
imaging right it's kind of not the
general computer vision and things it's
a niche oh yes yes
oh yeah sure you know most of the
algorithms are not published of course
okay and just to convince you a little
bit more than now the planning is really
really cool with medical imaging
so in mkhaya 2017 Makai is like the cvpr
of medical imaging it's the largest
conference there and last year in Kyushu
adventure which is one of the well known
figures in the planning was the keynote
speaker and really you know everything
there was about deep learning so we kind
of reached in medical imaging which was
switched several years ago in Kunduz
English so what happened until 2015
let's say and I would argue that people
thought that simple deep learning is
cool but not for medical age and and you
know when you look on the image about to
set right this is a I guess some are you
are familiar with it it has 1 million
annotated images right and if you think
about medical data even just to have the
medical data and this large numbers you
need some kind of a partnership with the
hospital right and for that you probably
need to be a big company or you know you
need to work hard for that just to get
the data and then when you have the data
you need to annotate this data and of
course you cannot use just mechanical
torque right in
like in the image space and you need
really medical experts which are rare
and very very expensive so even if you
have access to this a large datasets
annotations you will never reached 1
million per count it will not happen
more than that with some of the labels
around are not well defined
ok yeah so get into this problem oh yes
yes indeed ok so what can we do let's
look on some of the potential solutions
or facilitators for them
okay so first transfer money right in
computer vision when you have a new
problem and let's say now you want to
classify furnishers what do you do you
take your pre-trained image and network
right and fine-tune it on your new
problem even though you have you know
small beta and then you're good
however you know mental images are very
very different from medical images right
it's a completely different setup even
between different medical imaging
settings the physics of how the image is
required are very different but anyway
the data is very different and these
transfer learning it was trying
sometimes successfully but you know with
not that much success main contributor
vision and this is a very important
point what do you do if you want to
operate in 3d right so we'll say now you
have your city scan and you can create
the volume out of it and you know
potentially you want to use your all the
3d context take the right not just
operate in 2d and so now if you want to
operate and create the 3d architecture
you cannot just use images right so so
there is a limitation you don't have
this image net for 3d thing ok another
thing that you can do I our day talk
mentation
and those are actually used very very
heavily in medical imaging so you know
random floats and rotations and you know
basic stuff like that you know everybody
does it but there are some you know more
advanced things here also but but this
is really you know a research area where
you know people are looking into it
because they take the problem and so
this is from that algorithmic side and
and actually you know in general the
problem you know you do have some
starting point so it's not like you
cannot do anything you still have some
public deficit so if you want to start
working on medical imaging try to do
some stuff with that so you can use
public datasets and actually here I put
a link to this Grand Challenges though
so you know I think most of the
challenges are covering them so you can
take a look of course if you know in the
challenge you have a several hundred
annotated cases for specific problem you
will be lucky okay so it's not like big
data it's really small data but it's not
weak and you can use it in some cases
it's even for commercial use so you can
check it out
and actually another exciting thing that
happened that this week a new data set
was released which is called depletion
and this is kind of more large-scale
about person it has a ten thousand
lesion images live images with annotated
visions so this is even pretty large for
this domain so I encourage you to check
it up okay so another problem like we
mentioned even if it have our labels
they are noisy and in many cases the
agreement between the radiologists
themselves can be as low as 70 percent'
let's say okay
and so now when you have those
Northy labels how can you achieve better
performance than human right if you're
you know you're using supervised
learning and your annotations are far
from being perfect right so so what can
you do
and one thing is kind of obvious is that
if you have additional information use
right so let's say you want to know if
see if occlusion is cancerous or not if
you have Barb's information it can be
helpful right some things like that but
in many cases you don't have it of
course surf let's say for segmentation
problems you of course will not have
such data and another is you know point
to consider is that even though you
don't have this large data set in
general you know it's not that much
important that your training set will be
very clean right so if you will have in
your training set a lot of data and it
will be noisy and let's say validations
when will be done not by the most expert
or the ologies but with some you know
person that is less expert in the field
so this can be still fine what is
important is that your test that will be
of high quality right because sometimes
our you know if you have bad deficits
and and it is noise it still can be okay
it's low quality because you don't want
the radiation most of the medical
imaging you're obliged to use as little
radiation as possible thus the quality
is usually very low quality its image
yes it's a it's a different thing it's a
different thing and then specific
radiation is only for City right if
we're talking about tomorrow it's not
really a problem but but here here it's
the the quality of your annotations but
saying having collected the data for you
for your medical imaging company another
problem that we have if you are not
there is Courreges by now we have a lot
of problems in this soup so another
problem that we have is that we have a
lot of different machine vendors ok so
now even if you have a different
research and you got very nice results
on your data and I want to deploy your
data in different different places in
the world you need to remember that you
know there will be the images will be
different there will be different
scanning protocols and of course you
have the demographic factors of you know
different people in different places so
and actually this is a very difficult
problem and we should remember that it's
not really possible in this training
sense to cover all this really it's just
impossible ok and one thing that you
know people look on this regard is
things like domain adaptation ok but you
can potentially solve it in different
ways but this is also kind of a vibrant
research area ok another thing a 3d data
so I already talked about it a little
bit but we would like to operate in 3d
data sorry so first we don't have a pre
trained networks when you're in 3d and
another point is that most of computer
vision research is including right so
now you have this new cool paper from
cvpr
and you want to apply ok but you know it
should be in 3d and in many cases
not that trivial and I'll explain why
it's also important to note that 3d
networks are harder to Train they have
more parameters they need more data and
this is a very important point you have
at least today we have GPU memory
limitations ok and and actually
typically if you're operating in 3p
we have [ __ ] styles like veg size of 2
or maximum before but it's not like in
computer vision that you have more than
100 which size the more than hundreds so
really if you want to take the whole
volume which is the let's say so
typically to the images are 512 512 and
now let's say you have 300 in slices ok
so if you want to fit this volume and
train those kind of volumes on your GPU
you would some you know reach this
segmentation ok so this is my medical
imaging we want GPUs with large memory
ok this is a must
ok and you know another problem is
unbalanced data and this happens
especially when we are looking for small
lesions in the big scamp okay these
things like that it can be protection it
can be segmentation but of course the
day is very unbalanced there and this is
why you know different solutions were
proposed like it's like it's sampling
hard- money and we have vacated those
functions like that ice loss so really
this is a big problem and and people who
are attacking this ok so now let's kind
of try to look on the segmentation
methods and try to go through the
history segmentation methods and to
understand
when you know that this trend started to
have some different medical imaging more
and more and why okay so this is really
I think one of the earliest works in the
field you can see here 2012 right very
very early
it's segmentation of my bronze in an
electron microscopy images and what
people did at the time is to treat the
segmentation problem a specification
problem so now we want to classify each
pixel that we were killed including and
we want to classify each pixel as
belonging to the let say lesion or
non-specifically here it sir when Broncs
in microscopy images and and now what we
do we are taking patches around this
point and and you can see here this is
also a nice trick to have big data out
of small data right so here you can see
that they had only 32 the images but
then when you take these the patches you
have 50 thousand okay so this is kind of
solved a little bit this problem but of
course operating in patches you don't
have this context that you want to have
so it's far from being being optimal yes
yes okay so next the additional people
and things that people did this is 2013
and this is the new centralized mutation
this time in MRI and this concept can
kind of until today some people are
using it so now they say okay we will
operate in 2d but instead of just using
one plane we will use three orthogonal
planes okay so in medical imaging we
call it axial sagittal and coronal
slices and we take each one of these
direction
we train a network for each one thing
and then we sum up the results okay and
this is kind of a trick to at least
somehow incorporate these 3d contacts so
this is also what people did and then
this is not medical imaging this is
computer vision came the fully
convolutional networks in 2050 okay and
this was a kind of a big leap in image
segmentation in general and what
happened happened here was the first
business the first time that people
could actually fit in a 2d image and
have an segmentation output without the
need to use these patches and also this
was done in an efficient way in a fully
conversional way so it was also pretty
quick okay so this was really a game
changer I think this paper has something
like 5,000 sin side patients No nice
paper okay so those are fully
convolutional networks and then came the
unit and the unit is is actually came
from the medical imaging community and
now it is used you know in many other
domains in computer vision but the idea
here in the unit architecture is that we
have some kind of encoder and decoder
architecture and we have those
connections lateral connections between
the encoder and the decoder and
different resolutions okay and and this
kind of enables the Grameen's to flow
more smoothly and we can get you know
features from different resolutions okay
so this is kind of the basic idea of the
unit and of course you can see the
number of citations here I think it's
the most or at least one of the most
cited papers in my college and for sure
maybe it's the most type
but anyway the nice property about it is
that if this is this was the first time
the people showed that using and they
have here three different experiences
using only 30 or 20 images is enough to
beat the state of the art okay so they
have here three different experiments
and they showed that they're using this
network and by the way and another nice
property of this network is that you
don't need the pre-training at work if
you just fill in the images you don't
you no need to use pre-trained image net
stuff you train it and twins you know
small data and you get you know best
results
what is the what is the size of their so
I actually yeah maybe I should have put
here the numbers I think the Centers of
the test was also kind of small ways
it's always small but but you know those
are kind of the standard data sets that
we're at the time and so what they
showed here is just by using the simple
training and very simple you can yes
[Music]
it's a good question and I think the
trick is already into the fully a
convolutional networks that when you are
using a fully convolutional network
you are kind of already incorporating
some you know a lot of different patches
so you don't need you know to have all
those different patches like they used
before so it's kind of fun I think
fully revolution of network is also
capable of you know training with small
number and
is just improvement over them okay but
but the trick is this fully
convolutional networks they kind of
internally take you know there are
additional words that say that there is
a lot of repetition inside one image
right so it's kind of note those works
but there are image statistics that show
you there are a lot of repetitions and
and I guess what it does is you know
because it's trained in this way this
promotional way you just leverage
generation it's a good question
but it's a general question for medical
imaging at the time don't say that
that's not the sense of people hands
okay so this is how people did research
in medical imaging you have 30 pages you
train on you have 30 images for test you
show good results okay so you have to
download it you know it's not it's not
like they did something new here they
just use it because there's a lot less
variation in the images in the medical
minute like in Contra select other
imaging like compare in computer vision
where you have a lot of variation here
it's more constrained so that's why you
mean on a few just uh potentially is
potentially have a smaller variation
because it's the human body right at the
end of the day you still have all these
protocols and different things like that
but what I I would argue this also
afterwards it's not like you really need
I mean this mode data you get best
results
you know from everybody else but it's
not like this is the best result
possible right see how it can have this
large status I guess you can get much
better results okay yes because most
images it's
not elephant three of us yes this is a
good question I don't remember
specifically what they did in the unit
yes yes so usually what people do with
cross-entropy they just try to
efficiently put more images you know
with the revelation okay so you kind of
artificially balance your data and and
it's of course afraid of between house
positives and okay so then came the
Venus which is kind of financial
extension of this and it's not not only
of Venus it it's something like at the
same time you had volumetric units from
Google website right it's kind of really
at the same time they came they can
another thing about this female is that
it has it had a new loss function
so specifically instead of using
cross-entropy
here they use dice loss okay dice is a
is a measure of overlap between two sets
okay and this is kind of the evaluation
measure that is used in different
variations in segmentation in general
okay so they said okay so this is the
evaluation measure let's put it in our
loss function okay this was the basic
idea but not only that this does loss
also handles nicely this unlabeled stay
and balanced data problem okay
so it's kind of if you want to to to
tackle this problem you can sometimes
use you know a lot of function that
better handles it so this is also a very
much use but they are really I mean the
unit paper
really the breakthrough and since then
there are lot of 3d architectures so I
cannot say this is something branding
this is just to show you there are many
different architectures dude this is a
cultic medic also widely use you can see
shears you know in case of the venous
you have much larger rules she have
smaller blocks and maybe a little bit
more compact I guess you know the code
is disk of course you can find it online
just very popular it has two scales the
idea here was to help to persuade some
different scales and at the end you
combine them okay just more compact it
gets in terms of memory maybe this is
better yes so let's move on quickly so
yeah actually there are a lot of other
different papers for example this is a
general generalized base overlap and
they claim that they kind of taken
better the unbalance the data problem
okay so this is one this is high res 3d
net which is kind of a more compact and
they are using here dilated convolutions
and actually there are many many many
works let's stop here okay I think this
is a nice thing kind of to show this is
an organized segmentation challenge
where you get seven different
segmentation tasks those are from
different modalities you can see here
liver tumors brain tumors cardiac better
hippocampus really really different
stuff and the idea is that you need to
train only one network for all of this
and this is kind of Ultraman the
competition and then you get three
mystery tasks and your network needs to
handle that and it can be sitting in
Mirai can be you know every different
so this is another challenge to try and
I think the submission is until the the
beginning of fall so if you want to do
this
yes you have two weeks to submit that
okay and finally I want to talk about
another trend which is kind of more in
the recent year and this work is the
from Google and here you can see kind of
different numbers right this is
large-scale data so here you have 130
thousand images okay this is for for
diabetic retinopathy problem and it was
annotated by three to eight of tomato
juice right so I guess you can kind of
understand how much money was put put
into this project right and they show
their performance it was quite similar
to to the positions and this is another
work this is from Stanford again 130
training thousand
images and a lot of people perform
training so this is kind of the new
trends to show that you know to put a
lot of money to make the patients and to
show that you are at least as the
physicians or maybe even better okay and
now I try to understand okay so what's
next so what if it was true we have you
know in September we had we have another
nikai conference so I try to look on the
accepted papers there and what I found
was that you know if you just type week
supervision or week something you get a
lot of papers and also things like
active learning are also there
so it looks like the direction that we
are going is that people have already a
lot of data you know it's not very
difficult today to get the day you can
partner with the hospital yogi you can
get
data the problem is with annotations
okay this is still expensive it's it's
will remain expensive and this is why
people are looking on weak supervision
okay unsupervised learning and week
supervision because sometimes you do
have some kind of annotations and of
course excellent because now that you
have this bunch of day they want to
select the best possible scans for your
expensive position to label right so
looks like that this is the direction
that we're going
okay thank you very much
[Applause]